MALE SPEAKER: Thanks so much.
Thank you.
I think we're going to start.
We're going to go
straight into cooking.
TY PENNINGTON: Let's
go right into the food.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Really?
OK.
How's everybody doing?
I wasn't expecting that.
TY PENNINGTON: So this is what
we do on the show, by the way,
too.
We have our home
cooks, which I think
makes this show so
much more different
than any other
cooking show that's
ever been on for
several reasons.
One, you can actually finally
smell it and taste it.
So you get to use your senses
that you haven't had to before.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Just
like they will today.
TY PENNINGTON: Exactly.
And the beauty of it is,
while we're on set, too,
he's letting me know immediately
when somebody's in the weeds.
He's like, that's
not going to work.
I was like, how do you know?
He was like, I'll
tell you later.
But he just knows.
But the beauty of it
is just being on there,
we get to eat incredibly well.
Because he can't stand
Kraft Services, because they
don't stack up to
what you can do.
So we all eat pretty
well, just like you guys
are going to eat today.
So to tell us what we're
doing, Emeril, today.
What are we having?
EMERIL LAGASSE: When we
discussed coming here
with my friend
Tiffany and her team
and our team--
first of all, I want
to thank my right hand
here, Alain Joseph,
for making this all possible.
[APPLAUSE]
As always.
It's been early this morning,
also starting at Times Square.
But thank you.
So we talked about
doing something
that maybe you could all walk
away with and try to do this,
maybe, sometime at home or
on the weekend or whatever.
And that is, if
you go to Louisiana
and go to New Orleans,
you got to have gumbo.
And so we thought,
why not teach one
of my favorite gumbos,
chicken and sausage gumbo?
So prior to Ty and
I coming out here,
we took a whole chicken, just
a regular a whole chicken.
If you want an organic, you
can do an organic chicken.
TY PENNINGTON: And we
jerk the hell out of it.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
EMERIL LAGASSE: Few
sprigs of thyme,
covered it with water
after we washed it.
And we brought it
up to a simmer,
and we just simmer the
chicken for about 45
minutes until the chicken
was-- and what we have is we
have the chicken meat.
Take the skin off.
We have the chicken
meat from the chicken,
and then we also have the stock.
And why the stock is a
little darker than a regular,
basic chicken stock is that we
roasted the bones after that
and then reapplied the
bones to the original stock
to give it a little
bit more color.
TY PENNINGTON: How did
you roast the bones?
EMERIL LAGASSE:
Just roasted them.
TY PENNINGTON: No kidding?
EMERIL LAGASSE: Yeah,
in a little roasting
pan in the oven.
They get a little brown.
They get a little caramelized.
And then we added that
to the broth to just
give it a little bit more color.
And some people would do that,
maybe, with a tomato product.
But in this particular
gumbo, no tomato.
It's very, very simple
from that point on.
And the key to a great
gumbo is the roux.
If you take the time and
learn how to do the roux,
it's not about high heat,
because it's about the color.
It's all about the color.
You smell that?
That's the roux that's happening
right here, because we're
starting to get that
chocolatey color.
TY PENNINGTON: Always
go with cast iron?
EMERIL LAGASSE:
Cast iron is best.
If you don't have cast iron,
you could use stainless.
You could use nonstick,
what you have.
But cast iron is a really
good source of heat.
So we got chicken.
We got our stock, and now
we've started our roux.
What's in the roux?
It's half flower and
half oil, vegetable oil.
I don't use any peanut
oils or those type
of oils which have a great
smoking point, only because
of people with allergies,
et cetera, et cetera.
So I just do either vegetable
or canola oil and flour.
Yeah, you can do that, Tyler.
That would be great.
No, no, seriously, I mean that.
Because what I
want to show you is
that when you're cooking, when
you're cooking with roux, which
is the thickening
agent, there are
many stages of where roux is at.
The first stage, which is
called the blonde roux,
it's not about how
high the heat is.
You guys can see that?
I forget where I am here.
OK.
This is the first stage of
the roux, a blonde roux.
Then if you continue
to keep cooking it,
then you're going to get a
little bit darker in color
like that.
And those of you that
enjoyed-- I hope you
enjoyed the gumbo
upstairs-- or downstairs.
I forget where we are.
But that was probably the
color roux that the chef did,
not so dark.
I'm going a lot darker.
I'm going a lot heartier,
a lot more rustic.
Then the next stage
that you bring the roux
up a little bit more.
And this is all about
temperature, about heat,
about length of time,
and about stirring.
You have to stir.
How do I know when the roux
is perfect for my gumbo?
It's easy.
It's two beers.
By the time you can
drink two beers,
the roux is absolutely perfect.
TY PENNINGTON: You know, it
does taste better already.
EMERIL LAGASSE: On a bad Sunday,
I burn the roux purposely
so I can have two more beers.
It's a great excuse.
TY PENNINGTON: I'm trying
to get this right for me.
It's getting darker
because of the heat.
You sure it's not burning
a little bit on the bottom?
EMERIL LAGASSE: No, no.
That's why you want to sir that.
TY PENNINGTON: Well,
it's getting a little hot
down there.
EMERIL LAGASSE:
You got to stir it.
And you don't want a hot spot.
Stirring it real good.
TY PENNINGTON: No.
My dog had one of those.
You do not want those.
EMERIL LAGASSE: No, no, exactly.
Now, the next thing
that we're going
to do once the roux is ready is
we're going to add a trinity.
And in classical cooking,
everywhere in the world,
they have a mirepoix, which is
carrots, celery, and onions.
But only in Louisiana do
you have celery, onions,
and bell pepper, which
is called a trinity.
Sometimes it's the holy trinity.
OK?
Stir that around good.
Thank you, Ty.
Now, the next thing
about Louisiana cooking,
about New Orleans food, is
about the layers of flavor.
TY PENNINGTON: Amen, brother.
EMERIL LAGASSE: The seasoning
is very, very simple.
We're going to use a couple of
bay leafs, two or three, which
is from the laurel tree.
We're going to use salt.
Look.
This is not difficult now.
And we're going to
use cayenne pepper.
Those are the basic seasonings
in most all Louisiana cooking.
Very, very simple.
TY PENNINGTON: Love it.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Now,
what we're going to do
is once we start building
this and we're layering this,
then we're going to come
back and re-season it.
Did I get you?
TY PENNINGTON: I'm
just guessing we
may need a little
moisture in there soon.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Maybe
you need another beer.
TY PENNINGTON:
That's what we need.
EMERIL LAGASSE: All right.
So once this cooks about
six to eight minutes
and we start getting
flavor out of the trinity,
then the next layer
that we're going to add
is andouille sausage
or smoked sausage.
Andouille, preferably, which is
a spiced pork smoked sausage.
But if you can get a
smokey smoked sausage,
that will work as well.
Chorizo will work, mostly
the Portuguese type.
Not the dry cured type.
It gets a little bit oily,
and it has a lot of paprika.
So it'll bleed a little bit.
TY PENNINGTON: Can you
get andouille sausage just
about anywhere?
EMERIL LAGASSE:
Just about anywhere
now, you can get an andouille,
in most grocery stores.
So as you can see,
very basic ingredients.
The hardest part
was making the roux.
And that roux took about 45
minutes to come together.
And then the trinity,
and then salt, cayenne,
and bay leaf is where
we are right now.
We've already
boiled the chicken.
We've already taken the
chicken off the bone.
We got the meat.
So now, basically we're going to
add another ingredient, garlic,
which is one of my
favorite things.
TY PENNINGTON: I'm
with you on that.
EMERIL LAGASSE: You
with me on that?
TY PENNINGTON: I love it, man.
There can never be enough
butter or garlic, right?
EMERIL LAGASSE: I know.
Exactly.
OK.
So how dark was the roux?
Just to let you know, this
is the color that it was.
This is what we
took out of there
before we started adding that.
It's about 45 minutes or so.
Slow, medium heat.
You've got to keep stirring it,
preferably with a wooden spoon.
TY PENNINGTON: See, you've
kind of gone from a Pinot
to a Cab is what
you've done, right?
EMERIL LAGASSE: Exactly, Ty.
Exactly.
Now what we're going
to do-- very simple,
is now we're going to
start adding the liquid.
The liquid should
be cold, which is
why you want to make
the stock in advance.
So if you want to buy stock,
you can buy preferably maybe
a low sodium chicken
broth, chicken stock.
Now we're going
to add the liquid.
And the liquid has to be
cold, because this is hot.
So if we added hot to hot,
then what we're going to do
is get lumps.
If we added cold to cold,
we're going to get lumps.
So one has to be hot,
one has to be cold.
And now what we're
going to do is
we're going to add
our broth in here.
Now, using the roux-- if you
could just work that right in,
Ty, that would be great.
When you're using the roux,
or any thickening agent,
it'll never be at its full
thickening ability or maximum
ability until it
comes to a boil.
When it comes to a
boil, that's when
you're going to know how
think it's going to be.
And it's only going to
get thicker as it cooks.
Because as it
cooks, you're going
to have evaporation,
which then you're
going to have concentration.
So you've got to keep that a
little bit into consideration.
OK.
Everybody with me so far?
There's a big test
at the end of this.
OK.
Now the biggest part--
TY PENNINGTON:
He's like, I know.
EMERIL LAGASSE: The biggest
part now, folks, is making sure
that we come up to
the boil-- so we're
going to turn that heat
up-- and to let it cook.
Now, a good gumbo, especially
one rustic like this,
is going to take about at least
an hour and a half on simmer.
Let it simmer.
You've got to let those
flavors all meld together.
We're going to taste it.
We're going to re-season it.
So when we taste it,
we're going to say,
well, it needs more salt,
it needs more pepper.
This is one that we have.
TY PENNINGTON: Thank you.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Hot.
TY PENNINGTON: Oh,
that's horrible.
Wow.
Where did the wine come from?
How'd you get that little
touch of wine in there?
EMERIL LAGASSE: Knowing
Alain, my right hand,
he has already re-seasoned it.
But that's when
you would say, OK,
I want a little bit more
salt, or it has enough pepper,
or I would like a
little bit more pepper.
You can always serve this on the
side, some sort of hot sauce.
Tabasco is good.
It's a little vinegary.
I like crystal.
It's one of my favorites.
And also, this is what they
call file gumbo or file powder.
So if we added file
powder into that,
now we'd have a chicken,
sausage, and file gumbo.
Does that make sense?
So this is always usually
assured on the side
if people want that flavor,
unless it's a file gumbo.
Now, here's what
we're going to do, Ty.
Always serve with rice.
You know what I think?
I think we could jack
this one up, too.
What do I mean by that?
Let's add more chicken.
Why not?
Let's add some green onions.
TY PENNINGTON: I always
say more is more.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Let's
add some parsley.
If you want to just
mix that in for me.
TY PENNINGTON: Sure.
EMERIL LAGASSE:
Thank you, brother.
Oh yeah.
TY PENNINGTON: I'll tell
you, you Cajuns really know
how to do it, man.
It's true.
I'm just saying, New Orleans,
it's some of the best food
not just in America,
but in the world.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Amen.
So now what we're going
to do is we're always
going to serve that gumbo
with nice steamed rice.
And if you want to get crazy and
do other flavored rice, jasmine
rice, whatever, that's great.
It's just regular rice.
Little bit of green onion,
a little parsley garnish.
There you go, brother.
TY PENNINGTON: So
there's no beans in this?
EMERIL LAGASSE: No beans.
TY PENNINGTON: No kidding?
Interesting.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Try that one.
TY PENNINGTON: And clearly
I was off on the wine,
because you said nothing.
[LAUGHTER]
EMERIL LAGASSE: Where
did you get wine?
TY PENNINGTON: I don't know.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Other
than where you had lunch.
TY PENNINGTON: I tasted
it a little bit then.
Oh, wow.
EMERIL LAGASSE:
Michael, I don't know
where you are, because
I can barely see.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Our
food team now is
going to bring out
samples of gumbo.
TY PENNINGTON: Yeah, so
you guys can try this.
MALE SPEAKER: So
everyone can try it.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Michael, do
you want to open things up?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So I was going to ask you guys
a few questions about the show
and about you.
I realized I forgot to
intro you guys earlier.
But one thing I think most
people don't know about you
is that you guys hold the
title of the highest pancake
stack ever officially in the
Guinness Book of World Records.
EMERIL LAGASSE: This morning.
MALE SPEAKER: As
of this morning.
EMERIL LAGASSE: We
broke the record.
202 pancakes, three feet.
TY PENNINGTON: And the wind
was making it go like this.
EMERIL LAGASSE: It was scary.
TY PENNINGTON: But yeah,
Guinness Book of World Records.
Someone's going to beat us, but
it's not going to be tomorrow.
MALE SPEAKER: I think one thing
that's interesting is-- Emeril,
we were talking about this--
is that tomorrow, October 3,
marks your 20th year on Food
TV, which is kind of amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
So I wondered if you
could talk a little bit.
When you started, you were
doing this, basically.
It was this in front
of an audience.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Yeah.
20 years ago tomorrow--
I didn't realize
it was tomorrow until
Michael brought that up-- I
was starting the Food Network.
And I think I was the third
or fourth employee at the Food
Network.
This is way before
Chelsea Market, which
is where the homeland
is over there now.
Basically, there wasn't really
anywhere to shoot 20 years ago.
I had got contacted
about shooting a pilot.
I didn't even know
what that was.
I thought he flew a plane.
Called me my restaurant and
told me about this network
that they were going to start
with food 24 hours a day,
and I thought they were crazy.
And I'll make the story short.
I worked with this production
house in Nashville.
I shot two different shows
before the Essence of Emeril,
which is the
anniversary tomorrow,
and I got fired,
because it was horrible.
And I look at the
tapes now, and I'm
like, what were you thinking?
God, this was terrible stuff.
Because I was a cook.
I really was.
I didn't know anything about TV.
I had my head down.
I was just chopping.
And I didn't realize that I
had to make this connection
with this camera thing over
here and people at home.
So a little over 20 years ago,
I got a call from the president,
and he said come to New York.
And we brainstormed.
And that's when The Essence
of Emeril idea came.
I was universally trained and
classically trained as well,
and schooled.
And the show started.
And as years went by with
The Essence of Emeril,
it did make it 12 seasons.
And then somewhere around
the sixth or seventh season,
I was going to quit.
I was just tired
and really wanted
to be back in my
restaurants and only
focusing on the restaurants.
But that didn't
happen, because they
lured me to do this
show called Emeril Live.
So Emeril Live had
a run for 10 years.
And it was a great
ride and a lot of fun.
And my whole point of
ever starting television
was just to make it evolve.
And if I could take the
intimidation factor--
it certainly wasn't
for the money.
Because they paid me $50
a show when I started.
It's the truth.
And it was a set up like this,
and it was really makeshift.
But it is what it is.
It's 100 million people
now in about 19 countries.
And it was an amazing ride.
And then I have done
some other shows.
I'm doing another show right now
for the Cooking Channel called
Emeril's Florida.
But I'll tell you what.
Working with Ty Pennington,
I've never had more fun
and never have worked with
a more professional guy
in television.
TY PENNINGTON:
Don't make me cry.
I will punch you.
EMERIL LAGASSE: He's as
hard working as I am,
and I think I work
pretty damn hard at it.
And we're having a lot of fun.
This is a really,
really good show
that debuts tomorrow,
On The Menu.
It's amazing to see how
these home cooks in America
have evolved.
And the food that we're
getting-- huh, Ty?--
It's amazing quality,
amazing presentations.
And these are home
cooks that are just
looking to fulfill their dream.
You're all about dreams.
And these dreams are coming
true for these people.
They walk away with $25,000.
I think the money's OK.
But having the rights
of saying, hey, my dish
is going on the menu at
Cheesecake Factory or whatever,
that's a big deal.
And I think it's going to
really click with America,
because for the very
first time, they
can actually smell
and taste the food.
TY PENNINGTON: Well, I'm
sure these guys can also
smell what it really is.
It's also a genius
marketing idea.
It really is.
It's genius.
You've seen something like
that before with Fashion Star,
but not everybody is going to
want to go out and buy a $600
dress.
I know I had on hold,
but somebody got it.
But I think what's
really cool about this
is that you do give
people, everyday cooks,
a chance to really
show what they can do.
And they're just like everybody.
They're just like us.
But the other cool thing is
some of these restaurants
that-- I know in the
city, we don't really
consider restaurant-- but when
I've been across the country
building homes, this
is where you stay.
You stay at a Hampton Inn,
and you eat at those chains.
That's what America is.
So it's going to be interesting.
Because I think
anyplace that you've
got menu item, to be able to
add something new that's got
a story, that's got some
zest and excitement,
I think it's also
a really good thing
for the person who
loves eating there.
So everybody wins.
And it's fun, because
you really don't
know who's going to pull it out.
Because they second
guess themselves, too.
Because they have to
go to the process.
What is interesting is Emeril
and I are the first ones
to taste it before anybody does.
And he doesn't let on anything.
He's like, uh huh.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
I watched the pilot.
And there's a woman who does
something sort of questionable
with a hamburger and a cake made
out of instant mashed potatoes
on top of it and then
some kind of sweet sauce.
And I'm curious, what are some
of the worst abominations,
crimes against
food, you've seen?
EMERIL LAGASSE: That's
probably it right there.
And hopefully she's
not in the room.
But anyhow, that's
probably one of them.
Actually, I went to
Ty, and I said, Ty,
you're not going
to believe this.
He's like, well, what's up?
I said, I think she's
using instant potatoes.
And I asked her about
it, and she said, yeah,
that's how we do it at home.
So I gave her a
chance to change.
I basically said something
like, do you always
use instant potatoes?
Like, hello.
So she used instant potatoes.
Do you remember that dish?
TY PENNINGTON: Oh yeah.
Well, I just
remember the texture,
because everything was soft.
And I was like--
EMERIL LAGASSE: You
could have gummed it.
TY PENNINGTON: Anyway,
I think that's what's
interesting is that you do--
EMERIL LAGASSE: But it's real.
And that's what they do at home.
TY PENNINGTON: And they
stick to their guns.
And sometimes he'll
give them some advice,
and sometimes they'll take
it, and sometimes they'll
just be like, well,
I know this is good.
I'm going to stick to my guns.
But the fun part
is, we don't have
to be the a-holes, because they
feed a room full of 100 diners,
and they're the
ones who really say
exactly how they
feel about the meal.
So the critique
comes from people
that really care about a
good burger or a good pizza
or whatever they love
the restaurant for.
And I can't believe we're
eating in front of everybody.
Oh, they are getting it.
OK, thank god.
Because I'm like, man,
this is really amazing.
You guys should try it.
MALE SPEAKER: Do
you think home cooks
are better now than when
you started, Emeril?
EMERIL LAGASSE: No
question about it.
I think-- we talk about
Food Network 20 years ago.
Probably when a group
called The American Cuisine
Symposium over 30
years ago was really
trying to change the face
and the image of what
American cuisine was,
because basically,
everybody else around the
world looked at us like a joke.
We had a few restaurants,
but basically we
knew hamburgers, and mashed
potatoes, and mac and cheese.
And we weren't really
respected for cuisine.
And I think about
30 years ago was
when that started to change.
And there were a lot of
serious pioneers at the time,
like Alice Waters, like Larry
Forgione, Paul Prudhomme.
I could go on and on-- Jeremiah
Tower, Jonathan Waxman,
these guys, still
some of them around.
But they really started changing
the face of American cuisine
and reintroducing
farmers and fishermen.
Because farmers
and fishermen, they
didn't think that was
cool 30 years ago either.
So why should I be a fisherman?
A, I'm not going
to make much money,
but nobody respects
me for what I do.
Or why should I grow really
great heirloom tomatoes,
because nobody understands
and respects what I do.
So that movement started.
And then 20 years ago, the
reentry of food television
started again after Julia and
a couple of them out there.
And it was rough.
It was a rough beginning,
because people still
didn't really quite understand.
And my approach was really
to take the intimidation out
of it.
My approach then, once I finally
learned a little bit what
I was doing, was that if
I could connect and not
make this so intimidating,
and make this comfortable
for you to want to maybe
go home and make gumbo,
then that would be cool.
And if one person does
that in this room,
then I might have
accomplished something.
So then the wave hit.
Then it started hitting.
And then The Food Network
started getting more popular,
other things, as we know.
But there was a long answer.
I'm sorry.
TY PENNINGTON: The one thing I
think we all remember, I just
remember when you ordered
a salad and everything was
iceberg lettuce.
And then I remember the
change happening when, wait,
what's this arugula?
This is fantastic.
The more you started to see, the
more you started to experience.
And I think everyone has.
Now everyone really has become
so much smarter with food
because of shows like Emeril's.
MALE SPEAKER: I wanted to
ask you one tech question.
We're at Google.
In the world of food or in
the world of a home design,
is there something you wish
existed-- an app, a device that
would make your job
and your life easier?
It does not have to
be a Google product.
TY PENNINGTON: But
aren't they all good?
MALE SPEAKER: I can't
talk about that.
EMERIL LAGASSE: We've
come a long way already,
but that doesn't mean that
you guys are stopping.
MALE SPEAKER: I want some ideas.
We need something new.
TY PENNINGTON: Well,
I would say this.
It's funny-- we're
similar in many ways,
because I'm old school, but I'm
also new school in the sense
that I build homes.
I built some really
new homes, and we
brought in some incredible
technology that allows you
to-- these days,
let's be honest,
your device is what you
plug in to your house now.
That's your temperature.
For the first time,
it's showing us
how much energy
we can save, which
I think is a very
positive thing.
It's keeps the mind
about, oh yeah,
this is how much I'm wasting.
Holy shit.
I didn't realize that until
someone finally showed me
how much I'm wasting.
But at the same time,
you're kind of nervous
that if it all goes down,
where's the manual button.
So I think we're
all a little nervous
about relying so
much on technology.
Because it's like--
I don't know,
it's that uncle
that, you sure you
want to keep your
kids over there?
He's doing these crazy,
wild things, man.
And he's really good with these
inventions, but I don't know.
I think I've made my point
in a really bizarre way.
But yes.
But at the same
time, the technology
has also helped the
home building industry
completely as well.
So it's hard to say.
What would you say in food?
EMERIL LAGASSE:
For me, food wise,
I think, Michael, is that I
have trouble cataloging, which
is something that you
do extremely well.
What do I mean by that?
So I have an apartment here.
I have a house in New Orleans.
I have a house in Florida.
And I'm a crazy cookbook junkie.
So I have cookbooks everywhere.
I have a test kitchen in
New Orleans at home base,
and we have thousands of books.
So for me, it's
about cataloging.
I haven't quite figured that
out where I can bring something
to the stove, and I would have
my catalog based on whatever
region or country of cuisine
that I was preparing,
and I could easily get into
it without-- where did I
put that book?
Oh, wait a minute.
Oh no, it's in New York.
MALE SPEAKER: So this seems
like a good 20% project
for someone, for Emeril, to
help him catalog his cookbooks
and make sure that they're
always there in his tablet
by his stuff.
I have one very specific
New Orleans question.
I was in New Orleans
pretty recently,
and there's a dish
that you do very well
called barbecue shrimp.
It's not grilled.
It doesn't have barbecue sauce.
I don't understand this dish.
Why is it called barbecue?
It's delicious.
It's very peppery,
Worcestershire.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Well, I think
probably one of the originals.
It really started
as a home dish.
And we're very
fortunate in Louisiana
and along the coast in
Florida and Mississippi
to have really, truly an
abundance and easy way
to access shrimp pretty easily.
Shrimp boats are everywhere.
You go in New Orleans,
you'll find these trucks
that have ice chest
that are selling shrimp.
It's amazing.
So my research tells
me that basically it
was a home dish that
moms and dads used
to do with a lot of butter,
Worcestershire sauce, which
is a big staple of the cooking,
garlic, and maybe some onion.
And then when it
commercialized, it probably
made its mark at Pascal
Manale's in uptown New Orleans,
where you have to have a bib.
Because it's almost like a
vinaigrette, if you will.
It's like Worcestershire
and butter
that's separated with a
lot of cracked pepper.
And you dip it, and
you get crusty bread.
And no, there's
nobody barbecue sauce,
and they're not on the grill,
and they're not on the barbie.
So that's where that started.
Now, Emeril's this year,
this coming March, actually,
will be 25 years that Emeril's
has been open, my flagship.
And when I was
creating Emeril's there
were few dishes that I
wanted to do and create
for a white
tablecloth restaurant.
I didn't say fine dining.
I said white tablecloth.
And one of them was I wanted
to do barbecue shrimp.
So what we did is we took the
shrimp, and we took the heads
and took the shells, and we
made an extraction or a barbecue
base, even though it's
not a barbecue sauce.
Heavy Worcestershire,
lots of herbs and spices,
pepper, of course,
Worcestershire, lemons.
And this is reduced down.
It's a slow process,
a reduction.
It makes not quite a
paste, but more of a syrup.
And that's what we use, of
course with a little cream
and butter, the things
are the good for you.
And that's our barbecue shrimp.
And I created that, and it was
one of the very first dishes
that we put on the menu.
And the flavor of
it is just what
you've experienced,
except there's no mess.
It's a knife and fork
deal, and we serve it
with a petite rosemary biscuit.
So now everybody has
their variation on that.
But it's also fun to do
at the beach, because it's
an easy dish that
you can get shrimp,
and you can either make a
stock or not with the shells,
or you basically just
put them in a cast iron
with a lot of butter and parsley
and garlic and Worcestershire
sauce, and you simmer
them up until they cook,
and you serve them
with crusty bread.
TY PENNINGTON: But shrimp
are a little tricky, though,
because you can't
overcook them, right?
EMERIL LAGASSE: You
can't overcook them.
That's why I say they have
a built-in thermometer,
because luckily they turn
that color unless you're
using a ruby red shrimp.
It's like salmon.
They have that color that
they turn, they go, and then
they turn pink, and you
know that they're perfect.
But you can't overcook them.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
it's time to open up
to some questions
from the floor.
I don't know where
the microphone is.
Is it there?
TY PENNINGTON: I
didn't have it last.
I'm kidding.
EMERIL LAGASSE: There are
no questions in the room
whatsoever.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: What
advice do you have
for picky eaters and getting
them to expand what they eat,
particularly the adult
kind of picky eaters?
EMERIL LAGASSE: Adults?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Not children?
AUDIENCE: No.
So like smarter than a child.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Well,
that's what you thought.
I have a theory, particularly
when it starts with kids
and it starts at an early age.
My brother is an example.
Growing up, my mom
was a fantastic cook.
God, thanks that
she's still alive.
He would not eat
anything that she
made that had celery or
onion or bell pepper in it.
Also, the trinity is a
staple called sofrito
in Portuguese cooking.
So she always made
two of everything.
So she made one the
regular way that she wanted
and one a different way.
And I always used to
think, wow, that's wrong.
Now he eats it because he has no
choice, because his wife is not
going to make him
two of everything.
So he either eats it or not.
But going back to
an early age, I
think that it might have
started from the top.
Somebody told him
that onions and celery
or whatever weren't good,
or duck wasn't good,
or pheasant wasn't good.
My wife grew up right on
the coast in Mississippi,
in Gulf Port.
And when we met,
I always thought
it was strange that
she wouldn't eat fish.
And you could see the
ocean from her house,
but she didn't eat fish.
She would eat speckled trout
or she would eat red fish,
but she wouldn't eat the
other fish from the gulf.
And I couldn't figure it out.
And the reason that I
finally figured it out
was that there's a lot
of bad fish out there.
And fish should have no odor.
It should have no smell.
It should smell like the sea.
And maybe she wasn't
getting the greatest fish
where they were buying it
unless they went and caught it.
So that was one
mindset for her, that I
don't eat a lot of seafood.
I'm not answering your question.
AUDIENCE: No.
EMERIL LAGASSE: I
could just tell by--
TY PENNINGTON: I do that a lot.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Your facial
expression was continually
getting more and more
pissed off as I was talking.
Is there anything particular
about this person?
AUDIENCE: No.
Thank you.
That's great.
EMERIL LAGASSE: I'm
sorry I pissed you off.
The day is going to
get better, I promise.
AUDIENCE: So how
did the two of you
join forces to create this show?
Did you know each other before?
Did one of you call
the other up on a whim?
EMERIL LAGASSE: I'll
give you my version.
Ty can give you his version.
I've been a big fan of this guy.
I don't watch a
lot of television,
but I did love his show.
I loved his connection
with people.
And then he and I did
a project together
for Good Morning
America where Ty
rebuilt a hospital for children.
TY PENNINGTON: Give
kids the world.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Yeah.
And I was part of it and
did the food part of it
for the hospital.
And we met, and we
sort of connected.
And what we really
didn't know is
that his agent was
working on this show,
and my agent was
working on this show.
But he and I couldn't really
say anything to each other.
And then shortly after, Mark
Burnett and his team, Mark
Burnett Productions, said,
hey we got this great show.
You guys should
think about this.
You guys would be
great together.
And it really has been a blast.
We're really happy.
I'm sticking to my story.
TY PENNINGTON: Yeah.
It's funny, I'm
really good friends
with a lady who works
with Mark Burnett.
She's a very lady in television.
I've worked with her
on several things.
And she called me
one day and was
like, hey, I've got this show
idea that I'd like you hear.
And I was like, you want
me to host a cooking show?
She's like, well,
it's more than that.
And I was like,
OK, let's hear it.
And then she said, you'd
be working with Emeril.
And I was like, I
like it already.
But as she unlaid what
makes the show so different
and the fact that we're
working with home cooks,
that you really are
dreaming, and I realized,
wow, this is a
chance to really see
somebody who's got a
passion about something
really live a dream.
At the same time,
it's a challenge.
You don't know what's
going to happen.
It's got high energy.
And clearly that's why I was
brought in-- for the energy.
And what's fun
about Emeril is, we
didn't really know
each other too well.
We were both surprised by each
other's sort of sense of humor,
but we have two
different styles.
We're sort of like
Bert and Ernie.
One is like, and is like--
barely says anything,
but when he says it, it's good.
So it's fun.
I think it's a fun
show because he
gets to lend his expertise
to people who really need it.
Why is that funny?
And I just get to
lend non-sequiturs,
which is also my gift.
So it's a lot of fun.
MALE SPEAKER: I think there
was a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
So I'm pregnant, and when I have
my midnight craving for gumbo
but I don't have three
hours to make a roux,
what can I whip up that's the
essence of New Orleans in five
minutes that will give me that
spicy gumbo taste and then
I can just go back to bed?
TY PENNINGTON: That's
a good question.
EMERIL LAGASSE:
Do you eat pasta?
AUDIENCE: I eat everything.
TY PENNINGTON: I'm pregnant.
EMERIL LAGASSE:
If you have pasta
and you have this stuff, this
essence stuff, this spice--
AUDIENCE: Where do you get that?
EMERIL LAGASSE: It's in
a lot of grocery stores.
TY PENNINGTON: It's
in the essence aisle.
Next to Emeril's--
EMERIL LAGASSE: But any
kind of Creole seasoning.
And if you even just used
olive oil, not even cream base,
if you used olive oil
and sprinkled that on,
and you had a protein,
maybe some smoked sausage,
you'd be really close.
And that would be less
than 20 minutes, probably.
AUDIENCE: And Tums for dessert.
EMERIL LAGASSE: I'm sorry?
TY PENNINGTON: Tums, yeah,
to take the edge off.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Yeah.
There's nothing wrong
with bananas foster.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
Just wanted to say thanks for
taking the time to do this.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was
surprised that you
said you thought home cooks were
better today than in the past.
With Seamless and everything
now, and going out
to eat-- even when I was
young, it was a special thing.
And now that I'm
getting older, it
seems like everybody
can get take out
so easily, that food has
because so much more accessible.
I would be surprised
if more people were
cooking at home now than before.
So I was just wondering if you
had any reason why you thought
people were better
now than before?
Is just more
information, or what?
TY PENNINGTON: You probably
got all the good answers.
I would say in the
past, it was usually
one person cooking
in the family.
But I think, let's just say,
modern family has really
evolved in all kinds
of different ways.
So more people are cooking.
But I think there's more ideas.
There's more visuals.
Because of cooking shows,
more people are trying it.
Where some people say,
oh, I can't do it,
or well, maybe I'll try it.
So that's what I mean.
I think there's more volume
of people trying it at home.
There's certainly a lot better
restaurants these days, I
think, just because they've
amped up the game a little bit.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Yeah, the game
has definitely changed a lot,
and at home as well.
There are more people in
the household cooking now
than ever.
You guys are the
kings of that stuff,
knowing that statistic stuff.
Just about everybody
I meet these days
are trying at some level about
cooking, or at least wanting
to try at some level.
And then there are a lot
of things that have passed.
For a while, there
was a craze that folks
were having these weekend
parties where they were trying
to do Iron Chef things and
couples against couples
against couples, and a lot of
fun things started happening.
TY PENNINGTON: Like salmonella.
[LAUGHTER]
So I say all around, it's
got nothing but better.
MALE SPEAKER: I
think we have time
for just one more
question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm curious about your process
for finding the restaurant
partners for you show.
Was there a level of variety
you were looking for?
What was the thought
behind who you
picked to be the restaurants
that choose the dishes?
TY PENNINGTON: I love
that you pass it to me.
Well, thank you so
much for your question.
I honestly think it was
a simple thing where
TNT put the word
out that look, we're
going to show that is really
going to showcase home
cooks in a challenge to put
it on everyday restaurants
and chains.
Hats off to some
of the restaurants
who wanted to take a risk.
Because it is a risk when
it's a television show.
But more than that, these
guys, you've got to remember,
they're not just being involved.
On Friday night
when the show airs,
Chili's kitchen staff with
restaurants over the country
are finally understanding
what ingredients are going in.
Because nobody even
there knows yet
until the show airs
on Friday night, which
means that entire
staff has to be
ready to create that
dish for Saturday.
So it's a big commitment.
And I think--
EMERIL LAGASSE: And the
execution is incredible.
TY PENNINGTON: It's
pretty-- well, like I said,
I think what's
astounding about it
is it's never been done before.
And it is a big step forward.
But I think it's
one of those things
that as far as integration
goes and as far synergy,
you're still having
good entertainment.
You're also learning a lot about
food, but at the same time,
you're also giving--
advertising is changing, too.
And so if you can deliver
that and it works,
it could be groundbreaking.
So it's going to be
interesting to see.
Again, we haven't
answered your question,
but we have talked for a while.
EMERIL LAGASSE: I think
that TNT did really
a super job of getting
the word out in America
that this was going to happen.
People then submitted
recipes to them.
And it was actually a process
that had to go through that.
And then these
people were selected.
And it's their dishes.
It could be their
grandmother's, it could
be their aunt's, their
uncle's, whatever.
But it's their interpretation
of that dish or their dish.
And they're doing
everything they
can to try to get
it on the menu.
TY PENNINGTON: To
change it enough
that it would work on the
menu of whatever restaurant
we're working with.
EMERIL LAGASSE: That's
an important thing, too,
Ty, like you just said.
Because not everything
submitted can possibly
be either afforded or executed.
TY PENNINGTON: And 120
ingredients isn't going to fly.
EMERIL LAGASSE: Exactly.
TY PENNINGTON: But I think
they did really one of variety.
Because you can't
just have hamburgers.
You can't just have this.
You need a variety
of restaurants,
because you need to hit the
gamut of breakfast, dinner,
lunch, dessert.
So you want it to be able
to be constantly changing
so that there can be surprises
for the taste buds every week.
EMERIL LAGASSE: And we
have an amazing kitchen
staff on the show,
really amazing.
TY PENNINGTON: Great
medic staff, too.
Just ready at any moment.
EMERIL LAGASSE: A lot
of Band Aids, flu shots.
But the pantry has to
be completely stocked,
because we don't know what
direction they're going to go.
So it's a really big challenge.
It's a big shot for them
every other day on the set.
Because it's not only
proteins, but it's produce
and the freshest, greatest
ingredients that we can get.
TY PENNINGTON: It's funny.
I try and put myself in the
place of one of the home cooks.
I was thinking to
myself, OK, I think
I'm good enough that
I can create something
that maybe somebody would dig.
But I'm dumb enough to
pitch these really bad ideas
to the corporate executives
just because I'm sitting next
to them, and they're
just like, what?
But I'm like, it could work.
So anyway, my point is that it's
not just creating this dish,
but then realizing they
have to whip out 40 plates.
So you mainly go
from this person
has been cooking for your
family to, oh, by the way,
you've got to go feed a room.
And they all have to be
delivered, because each--
EMERIL LAGASSE: And they're
customers of these places.
So they know the menu
and their product.
TY PENNINGTON: And
then it hits you--
wait, maybe I couldn't do this.
I can deliver one and be like,
you're going to love this.
But 40-- what?
So it's fun.
And it's a great challenge.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, I
think you guys have to run.
They've got a busy schedule.
I want to thank you
guys for coming.
Please, everyone,
give them a big hand.
[APPLAUSE]